all right i have a clip for you guys
today that i think you're going to
really enjoy now i have to tell you i
have not been able to get a straight
answer as to who the reporter is that
asked this bizarre cringy question
yesterday of gensake during the press
briefing one person told me it was
someone from newsmax but the person from
newsmax has denied that they were even
there yesterday so i i don't know who
this is but i'm gonna play for you
such a cringy question this makes peter
ducey who regularly asks absurd
questions during the press briefings
actually seems sort of prepared and
there's a couple interesting things that
go on here
we're going to hear a question read
that is literally being read you will
see the reporter looking down and
reading the question
and what happens sometimes is
when you read or use a talking point
that you don't really understand as soon
as there's any question asked about it
as soon as there's any even remote
pushback about it
it becomes humiliating and embarrassing
this happened when i was in los angeles
and was interviewed by jessie lee
peterson
jesse lee peterson was talking to me
about obama
socialism because of phones oh so-called
obama phones and then he got all
confused about what even the talking
point is and when you just get a talking
point you're supposed to use and you
don't even really understand it it can
end up being a complete and total face
plan and that's what happens here now in
this particular case the topic is
inflation and build back better and
whatever
if you're allergic to cringe i would
skip the next 90 seconds okay let's take
a look at this and a lot of you know
twenty percent of this is jen saki now
having some tools for handling these
types of bad faith questions eighty
percent of it is the reporter just not
having any idea what's going on check it
out
okay go ahead just a quick question on
inflation
many people believe that government
spending is a big factor in the current
inflation levels by the way many people
believe is also good like that that
becomes a factor later as well can you
speak to concerns that spending plans
that come out of buildback better aren't
paid for and so could mean higher
deficits and more inflation in the
future aren't paid for
buildback better is paid for
entirely
okay so you've got to be able to say
where do you see that it's not paid for
because the whole thing with buildback
better was it is paid for now i'll talk
more about that in a moment you could
disagree with how it's paid for or you
could say i don't believe the number
right but you've got to be able to ex
because the whole thing with buildback
better was it is paid for
can you speak to the concerns that are
coming in that it's who are the concerns
from though
but who's saying it's not paid for
oh
this pause is maybe one of the most
significant pauses that i've ever seen
during a press briefing i'm even going
to back it up because every the pause is
everything here
but who's saying it's not paid for
because there have been a range of
economists saying it's entirely paid for
now
i jen saki bails her out jen saki should
have allowed the silence to go on even
longer but she doesn't she bails her out
um and that has been a priority for the
president
it has also been concluded by a number
of nobel laureates and experts from a
range of economic experts on the outside
that it will not contribute to inflation
so those are the global experts that we
would point to but there may be others
suggesting something else but i don't
know who those people are if those bills
do pass it will not raise taxes
now see this is now the here's the
problem
this is a completely different question
no
you pay for it through taxation that's
so so the ques it's she the the reporter
doesn't seem to even understand what's
going on is it paid for verse versus do
any taxes go up or two different
questions and it's just a mess this
person has no business being in the
press briefing room
well
something being entirely paid for means
that part of that is the highest income
americans highest that companies would
be asked to pay paid for means there's a
cost but you raise the money to pay for
it a little bit more
that has been part of the proposal and
part of reforming the tax system to make
it more fair so they're also not
expected to contribute to future
inflation then
like now she's just grasping its trust
the buildback better bill
again it's fully paid for we would point
to nobel laureates and a range of global
economists who have conveyed that it
would not contribute to inflationary
pressures go ahead i i almost am like
starting to feel bad because it's it's
so it's so so wacky you know the
question itself is just as bad as peter
ducey's questions but ducey is ready
with a comeback and he's ready with a
slicker goal post shift and that's where
she went wrong the silence is just
cringe-worthy and then she says so taxes
won't go up now let's first talk about
buildback better which seems to be
basically dead although joe biden is
going to look at whether he can do parts
of it through executive orders etc
there's a tax foundation general
equilibrium model which scored buildback
better
there's a congressional budget office
model which scored buildback better
the it's very close to revenue neutral
based on slightly different assumptions
now buildback better has tax increases
on the rich and some other different
changes to business taxes and other
things which would offset the spending
so the concept is very simple you do a
hundred dollars in spending but you take
in an extra hundred dollars that's 100
minus 100 right so you've got zero there
that's that's what paid for means in
this context
there is uh you know i have no interest
in obscuring from you guys
that
there is disagreement as to whether
things would cost exactly what is
projected 10 years out
and as to whether
the exact amount of revenue would be
raised that the biden administration
predicts there's a real question when
you're talking about spending projected
out years and revenue projected out
years particularly when the revenue is
not if i recall correctly
accounting for a dynamic tax model which
says well okay
here's how much you would get if you
change the tax and nobody changes their
behavior
but typically when you change a tax
people do change their behavior you've
got to account for that i'm more than
glad to admit that to you guys because
that's the case with any bill
you could say hey you know what
this actually could be a little bit uh
uh this could actually raise the deficit
a little bit because this thing's gonna
cost a little bit more and this thing is
gonna raise a little bit less money
that's perfectly fair and and that would
be the case with any one of these bills
the problem is the reporter doesn't even
know what's going on she seems dazed she
doesn't seem to understand even the
difference between
paying for something
and what it means to raise taxes or what
is what does revenue neutral mean she
just has absolutely no business being
there and jensaki handling it well but
it's not a difficult one to handle
because she's completely clueless
one of our sponsors today is bluechu a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time all you have to do is
take a short quiz on their website a
licensed doctor approves your
prescription the medication comes
straight to your home within days in a
discrete package no driving around to
the doctor's office or the pharmacy no
waiting around no awkward conversations
with your doctor all of blue chews
tablets are made in the usa the entire
process is just a few clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping